so another question for greg here
this is from joanna eck
in a previous episode you discussed
using chains and bands to alter the
resistance curve
and its effects as it pertains to
training for strength i was wondering
what your take is
when it comes to using chains or bands
when the goal is hypertrophy
yeah so that's a good question and that
is something that i
didn't really address uh in answering
the previous question
one thing i will note is that if you are
interested in previous questions we've
tackled
on the podcast you can go to
strongerbyscience.com
qa and there's a like linked archive
page
of all of the questions that we have
previously covered um but anyway so yeah
someone previously asked about
uh accommodating resistance and its
effects on strength gains
um sorry i hemmed and hauled about that
for
probably entirely too long but i didn't
address hypertrophy one of the reasons i
didn't
is that uh that is not what the research
is interested in
um it is a little frustrating to me
because
like if you're doing a longitudinal
training study
that's a pain in the ass it's a lot of
work in my opinion
like i i'm not someone who
i'm not someone who who will just say
like take every measure conceivable
so you can slice it up and get four
papers out of it or
you know just have a lot of different
variables you can try to p
hack but for a longitudinal training
study
it's such a pain in the ass like major
chronic uh measures that that may
actually matter to people
i say take them all and so you know if
you're
if your lab has like an ultrasound where
you can measure changes in muscle size
if you're doing a strength study just
measure muscle size as well
it may or may not differ between groups
but you're already doing the work
get that measure if you don't have an
ultrasound but you have a dexa
get leg lean mass it's not as good but
at least it's something
if you don't have either take uh take
like limb circumferences and skin fold
thicknesses
like there's regression equations you
can use to kind of predict changes in
cross-sectional area
not as good as either dexa or ultrasound
assessments but
you know again at least it's something
but anyway
a lot of studies don't do that and
specifically a lot of the studies on
accommodating resistance
using bands and chains just they assess
strength outcomes and don't
even attempt to assess hypertrophy
outcomes so i didn't really say anything
about it then um just because there's
not
direct research to fall back on but uh
the question was asked
and so speculate i will so um
first things first kind of the whole the
whole theory behind accommodating
resistance and why you might want to use
it in the first place
is that it helps match up the resistance
curve
with your strength curve and so by that
i mean that in most of the exercises you
do
you're weaker at the bottom and stronger
at the top that that's not true for some
exercises like let's say
pull-ups but for things like you know
squats um
generally deadlifts even though some
conventional pullers are weaker at the
top
uh bench press shoulder press
uh pretty much anything in like the
squatting and pressing categories at
least
most people are going to be quite a bit
stronger at the
top of the rep than at the bottom and so
when you attach
chains or bands to the bar it helps
match up the resistance curve with your
strength curve
instead of moving 400 pounds through an
entire range of motion
where at the weakest point you can lift
400 pounds into the strongest point you
can lift 500 pounds
you can put you know 80 pounds of band
tension on the bar
with none at the bottom so that at the
bottom it's 400 pounds it's still very
challenging
at the top it's 480 which is much more
similar to the 500 pounds of force you
would be capable of producing
so that's kind of what accommodating
resistance does for you
and so the question is could that help
with
hypertrophy and
i think in general just to to tip my
hand a little bit
i think as long as you're smart about it
the effect
one would at least assume would either
be neutral or
positive um i do think
if you apply it poorly it could have a
negative effect
so um to start with
we there's reasonably
decent evidence that one of the things
that matters for hypertrophy
is exposing muscles to load
through a stretched position so if you
look at research
on full range of motion versus partial
range of motion
even if you equate to like a range of
motion specific one rep max
people tend to grow more when they train
through a full range of motion and one
of the
speculated reasons why is that it's not
just tension on the muscle that matters
it's tension
like tension in a stretch position
kind of plays a disproportionate effect
so
you know if you put the same amount of
effort into training
full squats and half squats generally
your quads are going to grow
more doing full squats because you are
low
loading your quads through a somewhat
stretched position
um and so i think one way that
you could kind of shoot yourself in the
foot using accommodating resistance is
if you used
way too much of it so you know if you
put so much band tension on the bar or
so much chain weight on the bar
that the lockout becomes a limiting
factor
then essentially what you're doing at
that point
is limiting the load you can place on
yourself
when your muscles are in a stretch
position so you know let's say
a good training weight if you're just
doing free weight bench press is
200 pounds uh if you put and let's say
you can barely just barely lock out
300 pounds if you were doing like a four
board press
if you put uh like
300 pounds of chain weight on the bar or
something ridiculous like that
um then you know
you'd essentially not be able to put any
straight weight on the bar
so you want to be challenging yourself
at the bottom end of the bench press
and it'll be super hard at the top uh
and
you know you essentially wouldn't be
exposing your pecs
triceps front delts to substantial
loading in the stretch position
and yeah i think that that could
probably do
more harm than good when it comes to
hypertrophy that is obviously a somewhat
ridiculous scenario
the people i see using accommodating
resistance these days aren't
that dumb about it but i like
and this could just be because i'm old
and i've been lifting for a long time
i remember when i got into it during
like the heyday of west side
people heard louis say oh lots of band
tension is good
and they took that to you know level a
million
and would just put like hundreds and
hundreds of pounds of band tension on
the bar
and so like you know they would
effectively not be moving
any weight at the bottom of a bench
press or bottom of a squat
and then would be straining to lock out
like the last two inches which is dumb
uh i don't think many people do that
anymore but
if that is something you do yeah i don't
think that's that good for hypertrophy
um so now let's address kind of
a more normal use scenario um
so let's say you do you are using
appropriate accommodating resistance
uh the movement is similarly challenging
throughout or maybe still slightly more
challenging at the bottom
but it's not just stupid easy at lockout
that's kind of what you're aiming for
with accommodating resistance
i think at that point one could make
an argument if you think uh tension
through a stretch position is kind of
the more important thing
that it wouldn't really do anything good
or bad for hypertrophy it would be just
as good
as training with straight weight and
there is
some reason to believe that that would
be the case so there aren't that many
studies comparing
um isotonic resistance training which is
you know the type most people do most of
the time squats deadlifts curls etc
with isokinetic resistance training
which
is essentially using machines to
accomplish what you're trying to do with
bands and chains
you can tell a machine you know i want
to
extend my knee at 30 degrees per second
you kick out as hard as possible and it
gives you
the amount of resistance required to not
be able to exceed
30 degrees per second of knee extension
torque um
so you know at the start maybe it's not
giving you quite as much resistance
as you're able to kick harder it gives
you more uh you're a little bit weaker
right at full
knee extension so it gives you a little
bit less there but it
essentially perfectly matches resistance
to
torque output um and so that's kind of
doing
exactly what you want bands and chains
to do and there aren't that many studies
comparing isotonic and isokinetic
resistance training and their effects on
hypertrophy
but the stuff that's out there kind of
suggests that
isokinetic resistance training doesn't
improve hypertrophy results relative to
isotonic training
which kind of makes me think that uh
accommodating resistance probably won't
positively affect hypertrophy either
probably not negatively affected but you
know kind of giving you the same
overall results one could make
the case that it would be beneficial
so another potential mechanism
or at least like proxy measure
associated with hypertrophy
is level of muscle deoxygenation
so there was a study that i wrote about
in mass a couple years ago
uh lead author was goto and it was
looking at
like full range of motion versus
constant tension
partial range of motion triceps
extensions and so
one group was training from zero degrees
of elbow flexion
to 120 so that's pretty full range of
motion
the other group i want to say was
keeping elbow flexion between
90 degrees and 30 degrees so not going
down quite all the way and also not
locking
out all the way and they found that the
partial range of motion group
experienced more triceps hypertrophy and
also uh within both groups and when
pooling both of the groups as well
they found that the total amount of
muscle deoxygenation
experienced during the training session
was positively associated with the
amount of hypertrophy that took place
um and so if you know if that is a
decent proxy for hypertrophy or at least
something contributing to hypertrophy
one could then potentially make the case
that accommodating resistance would be
possibly beneficial because essentially
like
you're never fully relaxing your prime
movers
when you're you know binging squatting
whatever
but near the top you can kind of relax a
little bit you don't have to put that
much effort into it
um and so maybe that's you know giving a
chance for
more oxygen to get into those muscles
clear some of the waste products out
and you know maybe constant tension is
like a super good thing for hypertrophy
um and so with accommodating resistance
it would keep
more tension on the muscles through a
longer range of motion
um i still think that if you're
performing reps as a power lifter would
with like a clear distinction between
uh the end of one concentric and the
start of the next eccentric where
you know you're standing at the top of a
squat for like two seconds to catch your
breath before you do the next rep
i still kind of think that that would um
negate any of the benefits of like
constant tension
type benefits that you may be able to
get from accommodating resistance
but if you're doing like bodybuilder
style reps
if one assumes bodybuilder style reps is
kind of more of a constant tension
approach
then i could see
[Music]
i could see accommodating resistance
possibly making that
even a little bit more effective because
you're making the muscles work harder
through a longer range of motion
which may lead to maybe more muscle
deoxygenation and maybe more hypertrophy
um like i said since the isotonic versus
isokinetic research
does kind of speak to that directly i
don't
like i would prioritize
that over my mechanistic speculation
about muscle deoxygenation
so i kind of think that it wouldn't
necessarily improve hypertrophy either
but also wouldn't hinder it
but i am open to the idea that it could
be beneficial so
just to wrap this up if you're stupid
about accommodating resistance and put
way too much band tension or way too
many chains on the bar
i could see it being a negative but if
you apply it smartly
i think it's going to be neutral to
positive i kind of think neutral but
i'm certainly open to the idea of it
being beneficial
especially if you're doing like constant
tension style reps